and Thomas Massey serves in the Congress
he did then he does now he represents
the Commonwealth of Kentucky Congressman
thank you so much for coming on I have
never seen members of Congress accuse
the other I mean there's usually a kind
of Fraternity in the Congress you're all
members of Congress 435 accuse their
colleagues
unfairly without any evidence at all of
committing felonies what's your response
to this to the lying from your
colleagues in the Congress
you've exposed so many lies tonight with
these tapes that it's changed my
perception of what happened two years
ago and I was there the the tapes of
people Milling peacefully about and my
hats off to your producers for sitting
over there and going through hours of
this yes but I would love to to you know
to unleash the resourcefulness of the
American public on these videos I think
they should be released you know I think
it's poppycock they can't be released
because of some security issues look I'm
the one who's supposed to be secured by
these buildings and I'm not worried
about releasing them they need to be
released in fact there was a Rasmussen
uh poll that just came out this showed
over 80 percent 78 percent of Democrats
and 86 percent of Republicans say that
all the videos should be released and um
and they should because as you said
Tucker you didn't have facial
recognition software there we also could
we need a complete catalog of all of the
feds who were there tell us who they
were let's go let's watch the videos and
let's see what they did because there's
some really strange Behavior Uh on those
videos of people behind the police lines
in plain clothes like touching them on
the shoulder talking in their ear
walking up you know around boundaries as
if they weren't even there it's very odd
I'm the one who asked Merrick Garland I
showed him the tape of Ray Epps the
Democrats didn't like it I had to show
it on an iPad for for Merrick Garland to
watch it and then he refused to say how
many feds were there but that that was
also in the Rasmussen poll 57 percent of
Democrats think that it's at least
somewhat likely that feds agents of the
federal government were not just there
but we're also encouraging people to
Riot or go into the capitol
it's very clear from the footage that
our producers bravely slog through for
three weeks and God bless them for doing
it that that's exactly right that
federal agents encourage the violence
that day we just we're just a TV show
and we we can't show people without
proof um of who they really were but I
agree with your assessment completely
that obviously happened Congressman
Thomas Massey of Kentucky thank you so
much for coming on appreciate it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight